obviously Knocked Up the movie Knocked
Up as Seth Rogen everyone Craig Robinson
is the bouncer at the nightclub and when
she's pregnant and she brings a sister
and the sister's older she's like dick
in this nightclub I feel kind of old and
the other girl's pregnant and he walks
up and he goes and Craig Robin's like I
can't be having no old ladies and
pregnant [__] up in here what the
[__] man that's funny that line in that
movie was [__] up but he's like but I
would I would [__] you up
stop that don't do that
bro what are you doing why did you have
that that was so creepy but perfect
imagine your first time on acid okay if
we just get those going
[Laughter]
oh it's horrible it gets closer to your
eye
very [__] Clockwork Orange exactly
thank you